how'd she work out for you boys that's
nice I'm gonna miss it
you uh you know ride somewhere yeah it'd
be great we were actually just gonna ask
if you would do that for us it's no big
deal hop in normally we don't do this
but I was heading out on a walk run so I
figured what the hell you know I love
guac me too bro can't get enough of it I
love it too I just don't know if I've
ever been on a guacamole run really I
drove the West Texas last week for some
killer guac West Texas yeah I drove from
LA to West Texas in this rental that's
hardcore man I plan my vacations around
killer guac I like to go to places
specifically for the guac writing a book
about it
it's called walk on the go dude are you
[ __ ] with me no why would I [ __ ] with
you I'm dead serious
give in to guac calm I have that's me
man a lot of people don't know this but
guacamole originated in mexico in the
1500s the Aztecs used to make it and the
Spanish conquistadors they came over
they invaded they bring it back to Spain
he's been huge ever since I love history
you know for everybody it's different
for some people it's the Sunday morning
crosswords for other people's double
penetration for me
guacamole man
it's just right up here on the right
oh stop thanks for the ride man and for
the hey what the [ __ ] is that man hey